[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
It's DevFest season
again, which means
there's likely to be a
community-run developer
event near you sometime
in the next three months.
Head on over to the post
to find your local DevFest
so you can hang out with other
developers and share ideas
about Firebase, the
Google Cloud Platform,
machine learning with
TensorFlow, web development,
and more.
The Closure Compiler is now
available in pure JavaScript.
It's a JavaScript optimizer
trans compiler and type checker
which compiles your code into
a high-performance minified
version.
Nearly every web
front end at Google
uses it to serve the smallest,
fastest code possible.
And now you can run
it under Node.js
with support for some
popular build tools.
Check out the post for links
to the docs, a demo project,
and some getting started tips.
If you have an
app you're getting
ready to launch on
Google Play, you
can nominate it to be part of
the Early Access collection.
It's the place for
new Android titles
that are running in open beta,
available for anyone to try
before they officially launch.
For more info, including
who is using this and why,
check out the post linked below.
Hutch is a London-based mobile
studio focusing entirely
on racing games, with more
than 10 million players
on Google Play.
For their latest
game, MMX Hill Climb,
they used AB testing
and game analytics
to improve the game
design and experience,
resulting in more
than 48 minutes
of daily active usage per user.
Check out the video on this
post to hear them explain how.
Google Cloud Endpoints is a
distributed API management
suite that lets you
deploy, protect, monitor,
and manage APIs
written in any language
and running on the
Google Cloud Platform.
Check out this post to
read about the newest
set of features and open source
components now in open beta.
This is a post by
a web engineer here
at Google who used the
Google Cloud Platform
Stack to create a bespoke
machine learning system.
It's a really cool look at
how to use multiple cloud
components together
for prototyping
full end-to-end systems.
And as long as we're talking
about machine learning,
here's a post on the release
of Inception Resnet v2.
It's a convolutional
neural network
that achieves a new state of
the art in terms of accuracy
on the ImageNet large-scale
visual recognition challenge
image classification benchmark.
For an explanation of what that
means and links to the GitHub
project, check out the post.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]